[Music]
yeah it's Monday night you know a Monday
night means that's right yes Monday
night mayhem yes of this this month were
giving away an entry to the bill right
st. Louis open so that's one hundred
dollar value it's a really fun prize so
whatever position you see up here
tonight that's gonna be the opening that
you played so you play one game every
Monday night for the other course of the
month and it's good we had a 13
participants in the the last round so is
that the biggest one yet extenuating to
grow and the prize funds keep getting
better and better so free to enter
unrated come on out come on out it's
Monday nights or what it's all about
around here okay so tonight no I don't
have my paper just to say who
recommended this opening but uh alright
but it's it's something that a lot of
people have requested recently so
tonight we're gonna go over the
nimzo-indian and okay the nimzo-indian
begins after the move d4 Knight f6 which
we'll see there's a battle going on for
the whole course of this game here for
the e4 square so c4 and now how will
black continue to fight for this well
White's plan is he's gonna put a knight
on c3 now he's ready to play the movie
for so black could play a move like d5
and transpose to the Queens gambit
declined and the other way is Bishop to
b4 and this is the nimzo-indian so
pinning the knight prevents white from
playing to move efore and so the battle
begins and okay in this position there's
already several ways III is a very
common way to play it's you know one of
the two main lines so hopefully we get
to do that in the near future to f3 is
also a possible move here but tonight
we're gonna look at the move Queen to c2
and this is the classical variation and
it's gone in and out of favor as
openings tend to do you know some
openings they stay popular for a while
and they go out of fashion but around
the 90s Gary gets far off he kind of
brought this back he started playing it
with great success and since then you
know it's been the most popular way to
play this at a
all levels you'll see it here in the
club you'll see it you know top and
grand master level just a very common
move so this is where we we're gonna
begin tonight the point of Queen to c2
is at some point we're gonna play a3 and
you're gonna you know take my knight and
I'll be able to take back with the Queen
and not ruin my pawn structure
so what weights gonna do is he's gonna
collect the two bishops that's always
gonna be his big trump in these lines
and why would black do this well he gets
something in return
- and that's development Queen c2 isn't
the best developing move it's not like
he brought another night out or got
ready to get some of his minor pieces
out so it's gonna cost him a little bit
of time and we'll see if black can do
anything with his development advantage
to turn it into some more serious
advantage that's the battle that will go
on so if black does nothing here white
plays a3 and collects the bishop pair so
we're going to cover three different
moves actually tonight the first game
will go over the most popular move which
is castling so a very logical move right
and the first four moves you got your
pieces out and you castle
so it doesn't get much more logical than
that and then he'll be ready to open up
the center alright
also we're gonna take a quick look
tonight have to move c5 which is an
interesting way to exploit the fact that
the d4 pawn was no longer protected and
there's a piece sac line that hasn't
really gotten a lot of coverage so we're
gonna go over that it's a very very
exciting game so we'll check that one
out and I should briefly mention there
is another move that's not played nearly
as often as the first two moves but it
can lead to very very sharp
complications so it's a lot of fun we'll
take a look at the move d5 okay so this
is a logical attempt to take advantage
of your development lead and okay I am
intending just to take your c4 pawn so
if you do nothing I'm gonna take your
pawn if you have to play a move like III
which has been played by Carlsen on at
least three occasions so it's not like
it's you know a bad move or anything but
it's it does block in your bishop on c1
so that's not really ideal but yeah if
you you know just develop one of your
pieces or something I am taking on c4 so
white will typically deal with this
by taking on d5 himself which is a
slight concession because after black
takes back his bishop has now been
liberated so he's got that going for him
and okay well I can can play this move
and it might seem like it's a bit of a
banal position it's gonna be kind of
boring I don't see any fireworks come in
we got kind of a static pawn structure
here but there's some very serious
complications that can arise and they
have to do with black playing the move
c5 here or on the next move the most
common move is h6 and white must make a
choice
going back to h4 is the most complicated
we'll look at it he also can play kind
of you know a little bit more boring he
can just take this and kind of get rid
of his advantage disadvantage was gonna
be the two bishops and so I mean giving
it away it kind of leads to a dry
position but if you're in a aggressive
fighting mood Bishop to h4 and because
black hasn't castled yet he's not afraid
in some positions to play g5 and then
follow it up with Knight to e4 so we're
gonna see this but first he strikes at
the center with the move c5 and it's
kind of annoying how you how to deal
with this I mean you don't really think
you can play e3 because after you take
now black can consider you know throwing
in you know g5 for the Queen check but
even after like Knight to c6 it's kind
of uncomfortable how are you gonna
defend your d4 pawn so the most common
reply here is to take on c5 and in the
nimzo-indian you don't want to be afraid
to play d takes e5 it's a it's something
that's going to occur quite often and
even though you are taking away from the
center black is gonna have to take the
time to pick up your c5 pawn now in the
future and okay it does sometimes give
you the d4 square for your pieces like
here you know a knight you can imagine
wants the d4 square okay so what's going
on here
first of all what happens if we attack a
pins piece this is not a very good move
but who can tell me why mm-hmm
that the knight can't move you mean yeah
we're just gonna lose a piece here then
white blender
how can white save himself he's got to
find the right move here got to be
careful
you have it okay and then yeah right so
he can either move away or he can take
your knight
okay so that's that is one solution but
you have an even stronger move do you
have it Queen a4 check okay this is
interesting but I think after I defend
my bishop your Knights still in a pin so
I'm gonna take it on the next move so
even better but let's go we're getting a
lot of a lot of suggestions yes
excellent yeah yeah if you just Castle
now this is a pretty nice for white
you're gonna be able to go round up this
pawn in the near future so yeah after
this white would have an advantage so
he's not really threatening to play d4
but it's something you want to think
about you know you don't want your your
piece to get attacked okay so most
players with black now they will play g5
and after you retreat Knight to e4 with
a lot of pressure on your position so
black is moving the pawns on both sides
of the board but he's trying to get a
lot of pressure on white before he has a
chance to get developed which is sort of
a the essential point of playing this
variation so we might be able to take
your bishop we might be able to get a
little bit more pressure on the night
you know we're gonna bring our Queen out
pretty soon so what is going on here so
the main move here III and he puts more
pressure on the position so if white
survives you know the next few moves if
he doesn't get it attacked and you know
just slaughtered right away then he's
gonna end up with a really nice position
because black has weaknesses on both
sides of the board and even in the
center so will black get enough this is
the the big thing and the most common
move here cuz now your knight is
attacked three times is to play Knight G
- e - well this is something that
happens a lot in chess time thinking
mostly of like the Cambridge Springs
where they get a queen on a5 a bishop on
b4 and a knight
for they all converge on your knight on
c3 and they get a lot of pressure and in
those lines it is sometimes possible to
play the move rook to c1 this is an idea
borrowed from the Cambridge Springs but
this isn't the most popular move here it
should be understood that you are
sacrificing upon because of Queen takes
a to the Knights and a pin so you can't
take the Queen but they're still white
should have decent compensation he plays
Bishop d3 and the game continues but
Knight G - E - this is the the main move
here and now another move that they
might scare you as white Bishop to f5
okay so now we're threatening some
discoveries on the Queen we're
threatening Bishop takes g3 which would
protect the bishop and unveil an attack
on the Queen so we got to be really
careful here
but white is able to get away with the
move Bishop to e5 and the best move here
is just a castle you have no good
discoveries even though it looks like
you can take on c3 and we'll see after
castling yeah we'll see here we go so
will these discoveries work so we took a
piece we attacks your queen and okay if
you don't take my knight you know you're
losing your queen but also I'm gonna get
a discovered check but you can take the
bishop and after the knight move
somewhere just move your king and here
objectively what should be very slightly
better but as you can see this is a mess
both sides have weaknesses everywhere
you know the Kings on d1 we got a lot of
pressure over here on your Kings side
nobody feels terrifically safe so if
you're into a really complicated tricky
sort of position the nihms Oh
d5 if we just go back here is a it's
very playable and it's worth looking at
if you want some some complications and
the fact that it's not as popular might
make it a really good surprise weapon
against certain opponents all right and
so this first game we're gonna look at
today this is the game between Alexander
morozova CH versus Alexander belli
offski from the 2007 European team
in ship so okay it started with an Enzo
and it was the classical variation and
here black played the most popular move
which is to Castle okay and yeah both of
these players are known for you know the
kind of their aggressive uncompromising
style and this game didn't fail to
disappoint us on that so it didn't fail
to leave us without the impression that
they're they're both in the mood for a
nice fighting game so this was a good
one okay so I hope you remember what was
on White's plan here if you just Castle
how let's see if we can just remember
that the basic plan here
well yeah what's my play here you know
yeah you yeah
was it yeah 83 excellent so we're gonna
pick up the the bishop pair here if you
play Bishop e7 white just goes ahead and
plays efore and you gets an excellent
position so he gets the big center for
for really nothing and hopefully you see
what happens on Bishop a5 white we'll
just play B 4 and C 5 and trap the
bishop so you should take here and we
put our queen on C 2 so that we didn't
have to ruin our pawns
so you take back with the Queen alright
and now there's again a little bit of a
divide historically the most popular was
this move b6 that was played in the game
the idea is simple enough we're gonna
continue to battle for the e4 square so
we bring our Bishop to the long diagonal
to keep control over efore because
White's next move is to pin our night
and okay with the bishop on b7 we once
again get to control the e4 square also
possible and a little bit different now
is d5 and this is not quite as sharp as
it was before because we've already
gotten the bishop off the board so
you're not going to be able to put
uncomfortable pressure on the c3 square
but it does ask you know a very
interesting question of black or sorry
you have white black is saying okay I'm
gonna take this and then you might have
to take back with your Queen which c4 is
not where you want to Queen that's where
you want a bishop because now black will
play you know b6 and Bishop a6 and
attack your Queen and sometimes make it
hard for you to a castle over here but
ok the other options aren't very great
either you know we can take this
but then again we'll be undone upon's in
liberating this bishop so that's not
exactly what you want to do either yeah
you don't want to play e3 for the same
reasons as before I mean now you're
trapping in your Bishop on c1 so we'll
take a look you know some a moves here
our Bishop to g5 or Knight f3 those are
the two main choices and blacks plan was
to take here and now you're gonna take
back with your queen okay so hopefully
we remember blacks plan here he's gonna
play b6 he's gonna play Bishop a6 and
you know it's gonna he's gonna make sure
so I'm at some point you move your EEP
on after Bishop a6 he'd be able to take
your your Bishop and prevent you from
castling so that's part of his point
white plays you know sort of a normal
move we want to get the bishop out
before we play e3 and Bishop to a6
so if you just play a call move like
Queen to c2 for example now black will
just continue with Knight to d7 and get
a good game you know after a plays the
move c5 so white here should play the
move Queen to a4 which prevents this
night from making the move that he wants
to play so now you're you're keeping the
knight stuck on b8 and what tends to get
a good position the main line goes c5
you take this creates a nice weakness
that you can you can later attack you
attack the Queen she attacks your pawn
you can take and protect your pawn and
there's a lot of games that will in such
a position in the following way so be
ready to to be underwhelmed here you
check you attack the pawn you check the
attack the pond alright that's the
famous game Carlsen kramnik and it's you
know like 20 other games that have been
played so that's a common way to play
for a draw it is quite a solid way for
black to play but we'll get back to the
ad the main course here and we'll look
at the main move b6 again we're gonna
put our Bishop on b7 controlling e4 okay
this is the move white always wants to
play because then he can play the movie
e3 and get the rest of his minor pieces
out am Bishop to b7 and here again
there's a parting of the ways
we can pick from two different moves the
most popular move is actually to play f3
which would be really nice for white
if black allows us to play e 4 then f3
makes a lot of sense and f3 is a move
that you you play often in the nihms oh
you know cuz you want to control the e4
square but uh black can meet this with
the move d5 so he kicks your Bishop Oh a
plays d5 and if ever you take on d5 he's
taking back with a pawn
it's gonna be hard for you to play e4
without seriously weakening your
position so the main line goes III and
okay you reach some position like this
without the Queen's and okay I mean you
can play this way this is certainly a
respectable enough way to play the game
but it's it's really comfortable for
black you know there's nothing you know
terrible for him he should be quite
happy which is why a lot of people have
switched to the move III with a very
unusual plan so you probably won't see
it right away if you've never seen it
before so we'll check it out in the game
I don't want to give his playing away
just yet we'll talk about it in just a
second Black's plan is to play d6 and
Knight be a d7 this is what he's gonna
do against basically anything white
tries here and from there he'll play for
one of the breaks either c5 or a five so
wait is waiting to see you know how is
black in a play in the center now a move
that you might find unusual if you've
never seen this position before
obviously you can play f3 and kind of
transpose until I have three lines but
after d6 naívi to which you're putting a
knight in front of your Bishop so what's
the what's the point of this is this
amateur hour at the club it seems like
something you might see next door but
the point is he's going to play Queen to
c2 you know for getting more control
over a four and Knight to c3 so his plan
is to you know fight for efore the
battle for a4 is not over so it's going
to keep going and it's gonna be a theme
for the entire game here so that's what
his plan is
I mean blacks plan was developed as
night and we're gonna see is he gonna
play c5
if we're gonna know a little bit about
his plan on the next move Queen to c2
and he decides he'll play c5 and here
it's handy to know a lot about different
pawn structures so white is thinking
here
if black ever takes here and you can
take back with a piece meaning you're
gonna leave your pawn here on e3 you're
gonna get a hedgehog style formation
which is what white is trying to achieve
here it does look a bit awkward and
clumsy to have to take back with your
epon so he's thinking to himself I
really want to be able to take back with
a piece on d4 but I don't want it to be
my night because my Knights going to c3
so he plays the move rook to d1 so if
you take my d4 pawn I'm taking back with
a rook and that that will happen in just
a second okay
but first black gets his Queen to c7 and
now we get a our plan we got our Knight
all the way to c3 and we got control
over efore so alright now he takes white
takes back and after a six you get sort
of the classical Hedgehog formation but
unlike the Sicilians where you see the
structure a little bit more frequently
the white pawn is on e3 naughty 4 so
this makes a big difference because
since there's not a pawn on e4 white
will sometimes be able to put a piece on
e4 show I mean the the most likely
contender here is this Knight maybe
he'll get to go to e4 later in the
future so we'll wait and see
alright so after a six white kind of has
an uncomfortable problem this is the
obvious piece that he needs to get
developed next but if he moves the g2
pawn is gonna be under attack and you
know known for taking a little bit of a
risk he decides okay if you want my g2
pon you can have it but taking
immediately is a mistake
so we'll take a look at that if you take
here we get our rook on the G file so
we're hoping for a compensation for the
pond in the form of G file pressure and
now after the bishop goes either to h3
or
on the natural diagonal where it still
controls e4 white can now play the move
Bishop to h6 and if you have to play g6
and lose in exchange then this probably
wasn't the correct way to play but even
if you play Knight to e8 White has a
tactic here so we'll see who's the who's
the tactical wizard and the audience
what would White play in this position
it's white to play here there's a tactic
yeah alright it's my work so you have so
if they take yeah excellent
yeah looks looks pretty good so what's
that yeah yeah I also possible is taking
first with the bishop and then yeah
swing in the rook over this too is very
powerful so you got to be careful here
is black in okay I assumed he he saw
that so he played to move h6 so do you
want to cash in your your two bishops
advantage here and just take the knight
and then get castled or do you want to
take the risk in that and say fine take
my Jeep on open the G file so in the
game you played Bishop to h4 which is
the more aggressive way to play and
black took the pun so good you're up a
pawn is this enough compensation is the
rook going to be active enough along the
G file for you to get compensation for
upon so and then he makes sort of an
interesting decision with his bishop he
goes to h3 I think I would have stayed
on the natural diagonal where I'm you
stay you keep control over efore which
would prevent the next move but he went
to h3 and sometimes you know he's going
to go back and defend he can attack her
Queen and he can even back the bishop up
to defend the G file but wait now found
a way to make use of the fact that he
does own the the e4 square Knight to e4
okay
so black took and white took back with a
queen and I think there's something here
black must have missed because white has
a threat here that I guess you didn't
see so we'll see
they'll see the threat all you guys try
to find it on the next move here but
with the Queen here our big plan is you
know to get the Queen over to the G file
we can shoot the bishop away we can get
on the G file somewhere and we can make
some threats along this file and black
just decided to play Bishop to f5 Knight
to e5 would prevent the the threat from
coming that he didn't see here so I'll
let you guys play the next two moves
here for white what as your queen is
attacked so what are you gonna do about
it
some people are standing up this
position is so exciting yeah excellent
excellent Queen g2 right with the threat
of checkmate so wonderful he stopped you
and now what did white play you get
what's the very next move you got it -
yeah Bishop e7 let's see so Bishop e7
house was played in the game so yeah we
see in this position here had he played
Knight to e5 the Queen would be
preventing the Bishop from entering and
okay and the knight can even go back and
defend if necessary so okay so yeah so
strange I don't know how he he allowed
this to happen but after Bishop to e7
you got some serious problems you're
either gonna have to give back the pawn
and you know let white get sort of a
crushing position or you can give up the
exchange he decided to give up the
exchange which is the more dynamic way
to play if you just you know let them
take your pawn here you just the
material is equal again but White has a
really dominant position all of his
pieces make a lot of sense and you can
play h4 h5 he can play Bishop h5 he's
got all sorts of moves and threats and
it's very uncomfortable for black which
is why he decided
sorry after Bishop to e7 to give up the
exchange and he played the move d5
okay he's hoping for some activity blow
up in the center maybe you know
something something crazy will happen
because you know the way King is still
sitting on e1 but white takes the
exchange and black takes back with the
knight okay so now he has to find
another attacking move here so he wants
to get rid of this bishop because if the
bishop moves he takes on g7 awesome h4
right excellent and now's a good time to
test your defensive skills as well so
not only is white attacking but black
here has to find a very accurate move
just to stay in the game and the thing
is he needs to defend the g7 square so
you might want to pause your video see
if you can find it at home but here he
played Queen to e5 okay so you can play
h5 here there's absolutely nothing wrong
with that but the queen is now
protecting g7 that's his big point here
all right so what are you gonna do is
white
well here white also points out another
inconvenient you know Pat point in this
position after the move Queen to g3 we
realize even if you train into the
endgame this position is still really
good for white so normally when you're
attacking you don't want to trade Queens
but here the endgame is very nice for
white so if you take we'll take back
with the rook and then whatever move you
make we can take on c4 first but we're
gonna play rook to g4 with the threat of
h5 and this is really really
uncomfortable for you so yeah h5 is
gonna come and you're not gonna be happy
about it
so okay so he decides I'll keep the
Queen's on the board I don't want that
to happen
h5 and the bishop gets out of the way so
black is you know sort of successfully
defended against the attack there's
there's no longer the big attack going
on so we've been focused a lot on the
King side but you'll notice there's a
lot of things you know hanging around
over here that Y can exploit
so he went right
Queen to c7 and it's it's tough it's you
know you're not gonna really gonna be
able to defend your your beep on because
even if you decide to go into this end
game it's also not good for you because
we just trade we take on d5 and we're
gonna pick up this pawn and this is
gonna be a very good endgame for white
so he decided to play a bit more
actively b5 and now a very accurate move
from white so this is good there's
several good moves here but he plays the
most accurate which is Queen to c6 and
you'll notice now the Queen's are lined
up on the sixth rank which will
sometimes matter it means this pond
can't move away and capture something
also the immediate threat is to take the
rook and when the rope moves away now
you can see the whole Queen side is just
gonna fall apart here so white first
takes on d5
you can't you know take back because if
you ever move here right you're just
gonna lose your queen so it's tough it's
tough he decides to get his King out of
the pin okay very sensible and we just
start gobbling up the pawns
so okay the queen is coming in is she
gonna get enough counter play it's hard
to see but okay now maybe you are
thinking about taking on d5 so white
pushes black comes in okay we we defend
and okay there should be a relatively
simple technical task from this point II
five he moves the rook here comes the
rook the ropes coming to c1 but it
doesn't really even matter so okay now
even here you know you can obviously you
can take this and then win upon but even
this is insufficient because I think
even even this moving block with the
bishop but this will force the trade of
Queens so in a position like this you
would have to trade the Queen's so I
guess she realized in this position you
know okay he's even the threats that I
think I have I don't get to do so it
didn't didn't last much longer and okay
one more move was played here
Bishop to d3 and alright black had had
enough
so yes it's not good he's gonna win more
material and you know everything's
falling apart and he's you know okay so
a very good demonstration there by white
of one of the the key plans of
maneuvering that the second night over
to c3 in a nice attacking game that
didn't work out very well for black so
that's what happens when you give up
control over efore alright we got one
more game and as promised this is the
the very exciting piece sack line will
flip the board around and this is the
game Li Chiao versus Wang Yu e so this
was in the in a in a Chinese tournament
so both of these players are are about
2700 today and this was played back in
2011 okay so we get the NIM zone where
we're seeing it from blacks point of
view we got the classical castling is
the main move we're gonna look in this
game at the move c5 attacking the center
and you know we don't really want to
defend it with III and blocking the
bishop so you're playing the nihms oh
you do always want to consider D takes
e5 and here the main move is just a
castle and we'll just look at this line
for a second and okay you get some some
playable position for both sides it's
you know certainly there's a reason it's
most popular also it's funny I analyzed
this move which is not the best move
with somebody that I used to teach and
he was very close to 1200 level and you
know every time you play this I'd say
you know that's not a very good move and
he'd be like yeah I know you don't you
don't want to move the bishop twice in a
row but apparently if you play in the
under 1200 section of every tournament
your opponent's just can't resist
playing Bishop to g5 in this position
which is a well-known mistake so I mean
what does black play here yeah so yeah
Bishop takes f2 and after the King takes
Knight g4 and you pick up the bishop
it's also nice that you've kind of
dislocated the King so flex up a pawn in
white can castle so this is a a very
good success for him so if you play in
the under 1200 section yeah you should
take on c5 here I guess that's that
that's the lesson
but the most aggressive and sharpest way
to play is night to a six the point is
we're gonna go pick up the C pawn with
our knife instead of our Bishop so white
goes through with the normal plan okay
you
he gets the bishop pair and now you take
on c5 with the night so here he can play
b4 you know you don't want to go back to
a6 that's no home for your knight but if
you go in as was played in the game
you'll notice this guy he doesn't have a
whole lot of squares that he can go to
in this position even though he's
attacking the Queen you know the only
other safe Square he has is d6 so I can
move his queen and take in trail of the
d6 square with Bishop Queen to d4 so now
we're threatening to play f3 and just
trap the night so okay for one more move
you can play d5 now you don't have time
to I play f3 because I have the d6
square again but white can shut the door
with the move c5 okay it's a very good
Grandmaster so what is he doing this is
not gonna get trapped in there and the
whole point of blacks play here is he's
going to get enough counter play and
open up some files on the Queen side and
get an attack going and hope that
justifies his piece
so b6 and okay f3 so you're gonna lose
your knight you have time to take here
and open a file okay so I don't have
time to take your knight
I'll take your knight on the next move
so here what are you gonna do well we
can delay the them taking our Knight for
one more move and get a piece into the
action yeah check right yeah the
audience loves a good check yeah so a
very good move obviously white doesn't
want to play Bishop d2 because that just
allows our Knight to take it also King
d1 you know not only allows you to take
here on c5 but you have an even stronger
threat you know so so those moves don't
make sense the only move that make sense
here is Queen to b4 and we're about to
lose a piece so we're not about to trade
Queens and you bring your queen back and
they take your piece
um okay how does house black really
getting enough compensation here for a
night it's it's tricky well he has a lot
of forcing moves coming up
here's a nice forcing move we get to
attack the Queen gain the tempo their
Queen to e5 is you know coming up pretty
soon the Knights gonna jump into one of
these two squares here and he's gonna
get a big attack before white develops
any of his minor pieces and so the first
move here rook to b8 and white played
Queen to a4 check which looks kind of
like a mistake but it's actually the the
main move here because doesn't this just
allow Bishop to d7 gaining another tempo
on the Queen yeah you know if she just
has to move back then this is you know
not what white wants to do you're
letting him get another piece into the
attack so white was banking on the
tactical move c6 and okay what's what's
the point I mean what if I just take
this what was white intending to play
here this one is a tricky one I mean
what if I just take it
this one yeah this one's a lot trickier
say yeah you really want to take your
time here alright yeah good job Dennis
you're welcome
Bishop to f4 wow this was the plan so
you take my queen I take your queen
you take my bishop I take your bishop
and this was a tactical point that he
was counting on in this position and so
here black is actually in a lot of
troubles so he's he's not gonna be able
to justify his piece sacrifice if you
end up trading some material here so
well done very well then
so instead play Queen to e5 a double
piece sacrifice so what's this I take it
you know okay so that's two pieces
you've given up now you really you got
your queen your knight and your rook is
that really enough I mean white hasn't
moved any of his pieces but that is two
pieces and here we're attacking the rook
so he made what's actually a blunder but
it seems like the most logical move he
attacks you so you move but he's
actually losing now so we'll look at
that the the best way to play is to take
on a7 but now your threat here is to
make a queen and then to take this rook
with check which would sort of you know
end the attack whenever this queen is
out of there so okay the check and black
here has nothing better than just to
repeat so this line has actually been
worked out to a draw which is why
perhaps it's not covered in a whole lot
of places but you know your opponent
really has to know a lot of stuff to be
able to even get a drawn position which
is not what you strive for when you play
with white so in the game just back it
up
rook to a2 so okay there's a lot of a
lot of moves to consider here you know
you can think rook be one Queen c3 a
knight move and so here a knight move
was played but be careful because one is
better than the other so there's a big
difference so
we'll see if you can work it out cuz
okay they both they both look pretty
good right but but one is better than
the other and that move sorry you do
throw the chicken I apologize okay so
it's this position actually that the
knight moves and okay they both look
really good right do you know the
difference
yeah why g4
just okay yeah you can play here another
thing is you can also create a flight
square here and so the real big
difference with this move though too is
now in a lot of positions you're
threatening Knight to e3 so that's
that's the big difference and if you
yeah if you play it this way black still
probably has the advantage here which is
the nice thing so even if you make a
mistake here you're still you know in
the lead but yeah even stronger is
Knight to g4 because eventually you know
you have that sorry III square all right
so there what's also you know we got a
we made a little threat here a little
threat so Queen takes a7 defending the
f2 square from really really really far
away so if you're playing like a blitz
game maybe you'll you won't notice
and you'll blunder your knight be
embarrassing okay but okay who's a
pretty good player here so how to keep
up the pressure
there's the move rook to b1 okay
threatening checkmate here white delays
the inevitable he makes a queen which is
interesting
y can promote to any PC wants and the
best move for black is to take it but he
made a queen a serious inaccuracy right
Danny Machuca coming in the door because
if you make a knight he doesn't have to
take you so maybe he won't and then you
would win but by making a queen you
force black to play his only move how
could he play so bad yeah I know yeah
see take it
check please take my rook because I'm
checkmating you in several different
ways but okay check and now we don't
want to draw where we're about to
checkmate them so we run away with the
kingdom okay a little bit precarious and
now after the move e5 we really don't
want to take that with anything or
Knight and Queen are in perfect position
if you take with a king then you know
Knight f3 is going to come with check so
sidestep at all okay you just get out of
the way and it's tough
we're threatening lots of stuff here you
got a defend c1 so work the sea till
night to e3 so this is you know the big
difference and it does get to e3 and now
white plays a novelty and the only move
so you didn't know this was all theory
so before this there was another game
between people significantly lower rated
than this game and in this position
white resigned so but in this game white
played the novelty Queen takes Knight
the only move so okay so you're losing
some stuff but okay you got three pieces
for a queen normally that's you know
very good but it's not great when all of
black's pieces are strangling you then
it you know the piece quality is is
substantially different so blacks black
still got him good here
so tonight came out and his last piece
enters the game okay here comes whites
attack h4 you know he's gonna he's gonna
play h5 but we can safely ignore it h5
and that white gets to make a big threat
g4 you know okay here comes g5 and then
you got to give me your queen and then
you get checkmated but he gets a there's
a very very nice way to finish this game
so it's great he's played you know a
fantastic game so far and he's gonna
finish it off with another beautiful
combination here so for the last time
i'll i'll challenge the audience to see
if you can find you know it's not the
only continuation but it's the prettiest
definitely so what did what a black play
here rook to e3 okay this is a very very
pretty move
he said who said no no take it so that's
the right idea not the right execution
yeah rook H - H - ok ok so you're saying
I can't take it this is interesting I
don't know maybe I can defend like this
yeah I mean still still looks pretty bad
for me so that's that's interesting but
yeah the idea here was correct
only we missed the fact that we're
pinned here so get rid of the pin rook
take c1 a very very nice way to finish
only one move and now hopefully we see
it rook to d3 and this is where the game
came to an end so yeah if you if you
take we take here we win some material
and the resulting endgame should be an
easy technical task for the very strong
Chinese player so yeah so a fantastic
game you sacrifice to pieces and yet the
best line we can do is that to get a
draw but it's very complicated and you
know you're playing with white you're
not trying to get a draw especially when
you're 2 pieces up so a truly fantastic
game it's a it's a wonderful one and I
have some good news for some people it's
possible that all have a large stretch
here where not only will I be here on
Monday night I'll be here on Tuesday
night doing beginner breakdown so yeah
there could come a time where I do
several beginner breakdowns in a row my
covers coming up with is a season finale
very exciting it's gonna be a good one
it's gonna be a good one so I want to
take beginner breakdown back to its
roots I want to get some of your guys's
games so we can analyze them the whole
point we're gonna break down is we can
bring in your games and we'll analyze
them so if you do have games you want to
analyze you can send them either in the
YouTube comments you can put them there
or you can
send it to info at st. Louis chess club
org and st. a spelled out so yeah if you
want to send them in with any comments
or questions that you might have about
certain positions that'd be fun and
maybe we'll take a look at those in the
next couple of weeks and as always you
know send in your submissions for the
other openings that you'd like to see
coming up here really soon and I hit
like share subscribe and thank you guys
for coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]